hey everyone and welcome to what was
that with Gabe Sanchez a trump endorsed
Q Anon believing Capital storming
insurrectionist was busted for Stolen
Valor and now the GOP has canceled
nearly 1 million dollars in ads form
[Music]
for those of you who may not know about
J.R Majewski he's a trump endorsed
Republican candidate running for Ohio's
9th congressional district and to get a
better idea of who he is here's a clip
from his campaign video
if I got to kick down doors well that's
just what Patriots do when I'm elected I
won't bow to establishment pawns or
power hungry radicals
I will hold my own and demand that once
again America stands independent and
strong like the country that I fought
for honestly this looks like every other
Republican campaign video nowadays I
mean forget proposing actual policies to
help people in this country just promote
political violence with guns and boom
you're qualified to hold office and at
his core Majewski is a cunan Believer
who has repeatedly promoted Q non
conspiracies on social media and in
interviews I believe in everything
that's been put out from q and wouldn't
you know it Majewski also stormed the
capital on January 6th he even claimed
to have helped organize and arrange
travel for others to get to the
Insurrection but at least impressively
Majewski is also an aspiring rapper and
I use the term rapper very loosely
we need to finish the war they wanna
raise all our taxes we done with them
all okay I think you get the point let's
move on now some of you may remember
Majewski as the guy who painted his
entire yard as a giant Trump Banner back
in July 2020. this 19 000 square foot
Banner took 120 gallons of biodegradable
paint to create initially Majewski
intended to create a national league of
families pow M.I.A flag before deciding
it would require too much black but
something tells me he's not the biggest
fan of that color he Then followed it up
in September 2021 with a giant mural of
Donald Trump and they say they're not in
a cult but majewski's magalon Obsession
actually started back in July 2019. he
painted a 13 star American flag on his
lawn for a veterans fundraiser as a
patriotic way to honor veterans which is
interesting considering that he was just
busted for Stolen Valor now Majewski
describes himself as an Air Force combat
veteran who is deployed to Afghanistan
after or the 9 11 terrorist attacks
Majewski has spoken on several occasions
about his time in Afghanistan like this
time did you serve in Afghanistan yes he
did
how many tours one
what what year were you there what years
uh 2000
2002 2003. or the time he said he was in
operation enduring Freedom you served in
operation enduring Freedom correct
absolutely Afghanistan yes sir or the
time he talked about missing his
grandmother's funeral because he was in
Afghanistan probably is I lost my
grandmother when I was in Afghanistan
and I didn't I didn't get to see her her
funeral now despite majewski's stories
of serving the Associated Press obtained
his military documents and they paint a
very different picture they indicate
Majewski never deployed to Afghanistan
but instead completed a six-month stint
helping to load planes at an air base in
Qatar a long time U.S Ally that is a
safe distance from the fighting and just
for perspective Qatar is over a thousand
miles away from Afghanistan among the
military documents obtained by the AP
was majewski's DD Form 214 which is a
certificate of release or discharge from
active duty it literally says during his
nearly four years of active service
Majewski served zero years zero months
and zero days of Foreign Service so
after the AP story came out Majewski
held a press conference to explain his
side of the story we show one deployment
to Qatar from May 2002 to November 2002.
what he did meaning me
or where he may have went from that
location we do not have visibility on
in fact the orders and the military
records that I've been able to
obtained from my personal files shows
that all of my deployments are listed as
classified wait what was that obtained
from my personal files shows that all of
my deployments are listed as classified
okay this excuse makes zero sense
Majewski is claiming his military
records don't show any evidence of
combat or service in Afghanistan because
they're classified actually you know
what maybe President Biden can just
declassify his military record so he can
finally get to the bottom of this I mean
according to Trump you can declassify
just by saying it's Declassified even by
thinking about it so then Majewski
tweeted out two documents to prove he
wasn't lying and that was the moment
when political consultant and army
veteran Fred Wellman entered the chat
with a Savage ratio as Fred explains in
his tweet this is a TDY a temporary Duty
meaning it's a short-term stay not a
deployment like Majewski falsely claims
I was lucky enough to chat with Fred on
the phone and he pointed something out
to me that I found very interesting the
TV why document that Majewski shared
online is not even his it belongs to the
staff sergeant that he reported to at
the time so if you look at the document
you'll notice that Majewski has
conveniently blurred out the name at the
top and other details to make it seem
like this is his classified record and
not only that but while Majewski was in
the Air Force he received a demotion for
what he claims was a dormitory brawl but
something tells me the real reason is
much worse especially since he was never
promoted after that incident and is not
allowed to re-enlist after being
discharged from the Air Force that's
suspicious
and if you look back at majewski's DD
Form 214 he doesn't have any medals that
are typically awarded to those who
served in combat in Afghanistan so now
we know Majewski doesn't have any medals
documents or let alone photos to prove
he was ever in Afghanistan majewski's
the kind of guy who tells you the same
War Story over and over again and when
you ask him questions about it he says
he can't say anything because it's c14
classified it's quite clear majewski's
been lying about his service for years
and now he's using those lies to prop
himself up as a candidate in the
Republican party however a day after the
AP story dropped the GOP cut all of
their funding for Majewski they canceled
nearly 1 million dollars in ads that
would help boost his campaign and with
the midterms around the corner Majewski
is all alone so now Majewski is just
trying to flood the Zone with frivolous
crap to distract people from talking
about his military experience or lack
thereof because at the end of the day he
doesn't have any well I'm Gabe Sanchez
says and this has been what was that
[Music]